la bretagne a une belle carte à jouer
côté tourisme d'autant plus que notre
région reste une des destinations
préférées préféré préférer les français
la bretagne destinations préférées des
français
on le voit les bretons crâne est avec
leurs climats tempérés
alors que tout le reste de la france est
en sueur mais pourtant pendant longtemps
ce fameux climat breton
c'était plutôt son point noir retour en
1981 une averse un coup de crachin
scénario breton pour vacances 80 le
mauvais temps breton l'été faisait la
une des journaux avec forcément les
commerçants qui faisait grise mine
si les marchands de cire et font des
recettes appréciable surtout grâce au
mauvais temps les commerces
traditionnels de l'industrie touristique
accuse le coup les années passent et si
toujours la même rengaine exemple en
1981 est ce que vous pensez du temps
dégueulasse
il fallait alors trouver des moyens
d'occuper le temps on a apporté des jeux
de société parce que on s'attendait
quand même un petit peu à du temps
maussade en bretagne est bon bah on va
jouer au petit show kart et voilà mais
dix ans après ce sujet en 2003 la
bretagne va devenir un eldorado pour les
français qui ont chaud pourquoi ce
revirement
un mot
canicule la canicule a semble-t-il
poussé les aoûtiens en quête d'air frais
vers les côtes du littoral atlantique
du côté des commerçants fini la soupe à
la grimace
oui beaucoup d'échos des gens habitant
dans le sud de la france venant en
bretagne pour fuir la canicule sur la
chaleur et surtout respirer le bon air
de bretagne donc vous payez pas du tout
ces rares commerçants disent non pas
pour dire ça
l'année suivante en 2004 l'appréhension
des fortes chaleurs incitent encore une
fois les touristes à faire cap vers la
bretagne
j'ai un niçois qui mcma complimenter
c'était l'année dernière qui disait vous
êtes le frigo de la france bon plus de
dix ans après l'été 2003 le thermomètre
affiche toujours des étés chauds et la
région naturellement climatisée attire
toujours plus la fin des vacances et
aussi leur déjà des bilans pour le
tourisme la côte d'azur a fait grise
mine cette année on l'a vu avant-hier
dans ce journal -30% et bien c'est le
contraire en bretagne beaucoup de soleil
en juillet du monde en nous aujourd'hui
la bretagne est la destination préférée
des français ex-aequo avec la région
provence alpes côte d'azur la fraîcheur
des été longtemps décriée est devenu
ironiquement l'argument numéro un de
cette destination et les touristes en
rigole tous pas seulement neuf votants
personne aujourd'hui
mauvais temps mais c'est agréable aussi
voilà parce que nous on alterne on vous
propose plusieurs choix c'est gentil
séguin
[Musique]